Hmmmmm
That's insane.
What it is, is a milkshake
and cereal on the inside.
Hot chocolate on the outside.
It's hot and it's cold.
It's cereal. It's exciting.
It shouldn't work and it does.
If you like sneackers and cereal,
then Kith SoHo is your place.
And now at Christmas,
they are doing this fantastic mashup
between Dominique Ansel
and this outrageously cool store.
Kith is always a brand that I admire
because of what it represents
and the way they do business,
the way they change as well.
I think this is something
that we have in common with the way
we run our business.
I do it with food
they do it with fashion.
How do you decide on the collaborations
you're going to do?
Because I think you get approached
hundreds and millions of times.
For me, it's just like it
it doesn't have to be like necessarily
food that we collaborate with.
For the fashion brand that
has this platform and this,
like, reach to people.
I mean, it's very similar to what we do.
Yeah, no. I think you guys have very good
energy and creativity
and you attract people who are like,
enthusiastic and passionate.
Absolutely, like, I think you had a lot
of fun, like testing all these recipes.
Like the team at a Kith, like,
our work very, very well,
actually testing with us
and thinking of the ideas together.
So we did a lot of, as I always do,
like, combination of like textures
and flavors and and pairing
what works the best.
It's a unique way of like, I would say,
eating and drinking at the same time.
And it's cool for the winter
because you get something
warm in your hands, but you
also get something cold to eat.
So teaming up with Kith,
do you think that is a good business model
for you going forward?
Like, do you get to bring in
a new audience when you're
working with brand like Kith?
I think it's always fun to partner
and team up with,
like some other brands
that are not necessarily related to food.
Our range of clientele
is very, very large.
I think that the team at Kith
also have a specific type of clientele
and like somehow, like,
meets at some point
and still people are excited about
clothing and food at the same time.
Yeah, no. I think there's
definitely an overlap,
but it's cool to think about people
who are passionate about sneakers.
Also like, they recognize
that Dominique Ansel bag.
And I think in some ways,
if you have the aspect of a fashion label.
That's true and it's something
that we invested into.
You know, a bakery
doesn't always necessarily
needs or have
what looks good in terms
of like boxes and bags,
but I think it's part of our brand
that is a sign of quality as well.
Your pastries are exquisite
and fantastic, like your
playground is magnificent,
but this is like coming
from a different planet to me.
So the fact that you could
create something
that's crazy nostalgic
for people in America, but not for you,
and then come up with something
that's thinking totally outside the box.
How long did it take you to come up
with the milkshake hot chocolate?
I've been doing this for many,
many years now, so I know what, what works
and what doesn't before we even try it.
So when you try,
of course, you push the boundaries of like
and how far you can push to see,
like, how unique you can create a product.
Nostalgia is something I've been
fascinated by growing up in France.
And it's a lot, a lot different.
So our first came here,
you know, like learning about cookie.
People like eating cookies and
drinking milk led me to create
the milk and cookies shot.
So there's a lot of the creations
that I work with,
nostalgia is so,
so important for me.
Try and get this before
the holidays are over.
Merry Kithmas!